Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, you are in for a treat as I talk with Dr. Dana Anderson, forensic psychologist in the USA and host of The Killer Psychologist. It is a fascinating listen
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，你将大饱耳福，我将与美国法医心理学家、《杀手心理学家》（The Killer Psychologist）的主持人达娜·安德森博士（Dr. Dana Anderson）进行对话。这是一次引人入胜的访谈，
as we navigate complex trauma and what it is like to grow up in the States where there are guns everywhere. We look at how she rose above her personal circumstances and how she used determination, commitment and empathy to have a different outcome for her and her own children. It is a fascinating lesson and I absolutely adored it. I hope you find it really useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I had wanted to chat with today's guest for a little while and I am so pleased that we are able to bring you this episode. It is just incredible. It
我们探讨了复杂的创伤，以及在美国这样一个枪支随处可见的国家成长是什么样的体验。我们探讨了她如何超越个人境遇，以及如何利用决心、承诺和同理心，为自己和孩子创造了不同的人生结局。这是一堂精彩的课，我非常喜欢。希望你也能从中受益。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我一直想和今天的嘉宾聊聊，很高兴我们能为大家带来这一期节目。这简直太棒了，它
was an absolute pleasure to speak with Dr. Dana. And we just had a really wonderful connected talk where everything was slowed down, thoughtful, kind of curious. And I just absolutely loved what we did. So I hope you find it really useful. And I would love your feedback. I will catch you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome along Dr. Dana Anderson. Hi, thank you for joining us. Hi, I'm so excited to be here. I had a wonderful time meeting you last time and I was I'm so excited to connect with other psychologists because sometimes it feels a little lonely. It does, it can do. And we first met on LinkedIn, didn't we? Because you'd sent me a connection request and we're slipping into each other's voice notes. And then I was like,
与达娜博士的交谈绝对是一种享受。我们进行了一次非常美妙且深入的对话，节奏缓慢、深思熟虑，充满了好奇心。我非常喜欢我们的交流。希望你也能觉得它很有用，我很期待你的反馈。稍后见。你好，欢迎达娜·安德森博士。你好，谢谢你邀请我。你好，我很高兴能来到这里。上次见到你时我们聊得很开心，我非常渴望能与其他心理学家建立联系，因为有时这感觉有点孤独。确实，有时会这样。我们最初是在领英（LinkedIn）上认识的，对吧？因为你给我发了好友请求，我们开始互发语音消息。然后我就想，
should we just get together and have a chat on camera? That would be really fun. Yes, yes, I love it. A lot can be lost through social media. And I like to leave voice messages just so connotation isn't lost in text to just say, Hi, I'm happy to meet you, or let's get together or something like that. So it seems more personable. I definitely agree. And when we met for like a pre podcast chat, and that was a few weeks ago now, wasn't it? And we just had had so much fun didn't we yeah maybe it's like the bonding of psychologists we I know what you've been through like you know we've been through the school with the program like we have some understanding and we're both uh entrepreneurs now we've started our
我们要不要干脆连线聊聊？那一定会很有趣。是的，是的，我喜欢这样。社交媒体上可能会丢失很多信息。我喜欢留语音信息，这样就不会因为文字而丢失语调，只是想说“你好，很高兴认识你”或者“我们聚聚吧”之类的。这样感觉更有人情味。我绝对同意。我们进行播客前的那次聊天，那是几周前的事了，对吧？我们聊得非常开心，不是吗？是的，也许这就是心理学家之间的共鸣。我知道你经历过什么，我们都经历过学校的课程，我们有一些共同的理解，而且我们现在都是企业家，我们创办了
own business and I want to learn from others that have not only gotten their psychology degree but now you're an entrepreneur you're a CEO you are making it all on your own and that is something that we're not taught in school how to run a business absolutely and and it's it's I find it really empowering and almost moves me to tears a little bit to to hear you call me a business owner and an entrepreneur and a CEO and actually to begin with when I first started so I started my company in 2019 I was almost a little bit embarrassed of my little business. And it was, but actually, along my journey, you know, we're currently speaking in, where are we, April, let's look at my calendar, April 2024, I would have failed the MMSE on that one, wouldn't I? April 2024. And I feel so proud. You know, that's been my my development my growth I'm so proud to be a psychologist but also to be a businesswoman you should be proud because there was a day in time when women weren't psychologists. They weren't accepted.
自己的事业。我想向那些不仅获得了心理学学位，而且现在是企业家、首席执行官、完全靠自己打拼的人学习，这是学校里没有教过我们的——如何经营企业。绝对是这样，我感到非常振奋，甚至听到你称呼我为企业主、企业家和首席执行官时，我都有点热泪盈眶。事实上，刚开始的时候，也就是2019年我创办公司时，我对自己的小生意还有点不好意思。但实际上，在我的旅程中，你知道，我们现在是在——让我们看看日历——2024年4月，如果是在那个时候，我肯定会没通过简易精神状态检查（MMSE），对吧？2024年4月。我感到非常自豪。你知道，这就是我的发展和成长。我为自己是一名心理学家感到自豪，同时也为自己是一名女商人感到自豪。你应该感到自豪，因为曾经有一段时间，女性还不能成为心理学家。她们不被接受。
They weren't allowed. The first woman that got her PhD, they wouldn't recognize her as being a psychologist. And I always think of that. Right? How would you like to be her? I think she'd be proud of us now, right? So her cohort would have been able to call themselves psychologists, but she wouldn't.
她们不被允许。第一位获得博士学位的女性，他们甚至不承认她是心理学家。我总是想到这一点。对吧？你愿意成为她吗？我想她现在会为我们感到骄傲，对吧？她的同学可以称自己为心理学家，但她却不能。
Or she was an individual PhD, so she wasn't able to get that title. All of the men that got, I mean, historically, it was white men, you know, particularly from privileged backgrounds. And they got PhDs and they were psychologists. And the first woman who said, I could do this too. She went through the whole doctoral program and they said, good but you're still not a psychologist. And she's like, rude. And so, so much has changed through the years. And I was raised in a very sexist upbringing. And my dad didn't want me to get an education and went through great lengths to prevent me from getting an education. And even like mocked and made fun of me, even when I was pursuing my master's degree. And he said it was just a waste of my time.
或者她是个人的博士学位，所以她无法获得那个头衔。所有获得博士学位的男性——我的意思是，从历史上看，主要是白人男性，特别是来自特权背景的男性。他们获得了博士学位，他们就是心理学家。而第一位说“我也能做到”的女性，她完成了整个博士课程，他们却说：“很好，但你仍然不是心理学家。”她说：“真粗鲁。”所以，多年来发生了很多变化。我在一个非常性别歧视的环境中长大。我父亲不想让我接受教育，并竭尽全力阻止我接受教育。甚至在我攻读硕士学位时，他还嘲笑和戏弄我。他说这只是在浪费我的时间。
Who did I think I was? What was I doing? And I thought, what am I doing? But then I thought, how could I go wrong to seek information? How could that be bad? What if I learned something I hadn't known? What if he's wrong? What if we're all wrong? How about I just know more, and then I'll decide. And then I remember, he definitely didn't want me to pursue psychology. None of my family did. They were very religious
我以为我是谁？我在做什么？我想，我到底在做什么？但后来我想，寻求知识怎么会错呢？这怎么会是坏事呢？如果我学到了我以前不知道的东西呢？如果他是错的呢？如果我们都错了呢？不如我先多了解一点，然后再做决定。我还记得，他绝对不想让我从事心理学。我的家人都不想。他们非常虔诚，
and I got ostracized. They thought psychology was like the opposite of seeking God. So, so they, I was ostracized. So when I got my, when I got accepted into a doctorate program, I didn't tell anyone. It wasn't really for anyone. It was just for myself. I didn't need anyone to say, oh, cool, you got accepted. It was like, I'm just doing this. So I drove and commuted and I went to school and I didn't really, I was like, I'll just figure this out on my own uh it was met with such opposition but I think if you pursue something do it for the right reasons like it's it was for my own knowledge my thirst for knowledge and perhaps people in my family were just not educated on psychology and it it really impacted me yeah and it sounds like
我被排挤了。他们认为心理学就像是寻求上帝的对立面。所以，我被排挤了。因此，当我被博士项目录取时，我没有告诉任何人。这并不是为了任何人，只是为了我自己。我不需要任何人说“哦，太酷了，你被录取了”。我只是觉得“我正在做这件事”。所以我开车通勤去上学，我并没有真的……我当时想，我会自己解决这个问题。这遭到了强烈的反对，但我认为如果你追求某件事，一定要为了正确的理由去做。这是为了我自己的知识，我对知识的渴望。也许我家人只是对心理学缺乏了解，这确实对我产生了影响。是的，听起来
you've who knows we all need therapy but it sounds like you've done a remarkable job of not holding that against them they just didn't know they didn't know. They weren't in the state to be able to know how incredibly important that would be and how empowering that would be. But they clearly raised a young woman who knew her mind and was determined and focused and is going to, you know, she's got tenacity. She's going to show up for herself and she's going to do what she wants to do kind of regardless of what you think because she knows this is a good thing yeah it's funny my mom always said it's funny she said uh that I was always standing up on the inside I said what you said like when I would tell you something to do you would do it But you were standing up on the inside. So I like always had this, I want to say attitude, but like, I would be, I'm always sort of questioning authority and questioning everything. I think that can be a good thing. I'm not to be an independent
你——谁知道呢，我们都需要治疗——但听起来你做得非常出色，没有因此而记恨他们。他们只是不知道，他们不了解。他们当时的状态无法理解这有多么重要，也无法理解这会带来多大的赋能。但他们显然培养出了一位有主见、有决心、有专注力，并且拥有坚韧不拔精神的年轻女性。她会为自己挺身而出，做她想做的事，不管你怎么想，因为她知道这是一件好事。是的，很有趣，我妈妈总是说——很有趣，她说我内心一直很坚定。我说“什么意思？”她说，当我让你做某事时，你会去做，但你内心却在反抗。所以我总是有一种——我想说是态度，但更像是，我总是质疑权威，质疑一切。我认为这可能是一件好事。我不是要成为一个独立的
thinker and to question things. If you are going to be an entrepreneur and branch out on your own, you're maybe not a rule follower. You're not the nine to five working in a prison, a state hospital or something. You're not just a yes, sir person. There's problems in the system. And I saw that and I said, well, I have some solutions. I have some good ideas. There's also a lot of unethical things going on, and I'm not just going to comply. I said no. And that's one of the number one things you're going to see in, I'm going to say forensic psychology, but I think anyone that's worked in corrections, criminal justice, those types of settings, you're going to be exposed to things that are not right. That's a fact. And you need to question, not just be compliant or complicit.
思考者并质疑事物。如果你要成为一名企业家并自立门户，你可能不是一个循规蹈矩的人。你不是那种在监狱、州立医院或其他地方朝九晚五工作的人。你不是那种只会说“是，长官”的人。体制内存在问题。我看到了，我说：“好吧，我有一些解决方案。我有一些好主意。”此外，还有很多不道德的事情在发生，我不会只是顺从。我说不。这是你在——我想说是法医心理学，但我认为任何在惩教、刑事司法等领域工作过的人都会看到——你会接触到一些不正确的事情。这是一个事实。你需要质疑，而不是仅仅顺从或同流合污。
And so I call it whistleblowing here. I don't know if you have an equivalent term there or whether that's just the same across the USA and the UK. But it's it's knowing that actually we've got policies for it. We've got whistleblowing policies, knowing that if you see something that's not right, that's a danger to somebody or, you know, just unethical or not OK, that you actually protected as part of the whistleblowing policy to kind of bring that up. The difficult thing is, is that though you are in theory protected, it doesn't always obviously go down terrifically well in teams and organisation settings. But I think what you're nicely describing is that we mustn't acquiesce to the temperature of the water if the water is boiling hot, if it's toxic we mustn't you know this is why you know students on placement and trainees and assistants and new people entering services can be really enlightening because and when you join a new service for the first time because you are asking questions you are considering you know why do we do this do we
所以我在这里称之为“吹哨”（whistleblowing）。我不知道你们那里是否有对应的术语，或者这在美国和英国是否一样。但关键在于，我们要知道其实我们有相关的政策。我们有举报政策，如果你看到不正确、对他人构成危险，或者仅仅是不道德、不妥善的事情，作为举报政策的一部分，你实际上是受到保护的，可以提出来。困难在于，虽然理论上你受到保护，但在团队和组织环境中，这并不总是能得到很好的处理。但我认为你描述得很好，如果水在沸腾，如果水是有毒的，我们绝不能顺应水温。这就是为什么在实习期间的学生、受训人员、助理和刚进入服务部门的新人往往能带来启发，因为当你第一次加入一个新部门时，你会提出问题，你会思考：为什么我们要这样做？我们需要
need to do this this doesn't seem quite right this is different than what I've learned. And so we can update practice. But actually, sometimes services are, they don't feel nice to work in. They don't feel like it's respectful to people. It doesn't feel, you know, people being shouted at. And what we know, actually, certainly in prison environments, is that that's just going to antagonize people. That's maybe not the best way we could run our services. And, you know, that's just one example. But standing up for what you see and speaking out as such And I'm in California. And, and I was a whistleblower. And you do have to stand up for what is right, even when no one else is. definitely going to be challenged in these larger corporations and settings where over time they've adapted certain behaviors that they believe are acceptable. And as a psychologist, I feel like an x-ray, you can see everything, right? That you couldn't see before. Or like I wear contacts. So when I put on contacts I could see so much clearer 2020 right I feel like as a psychologist when I go I see things that people
这样做吗？这看起来不太对劲，这和我学到的不一样。所以我们可以更新实践。但实际上，有时服务部门的环境让人感觉不舒服。感觉对人不够尊重。感觉……你知道，人们被大声呵斥。我们所知道的是，特别是在监狱环境中，这只会激怒人们。这可能不是我们运营服务的最佳方式。你知道，这只是一个例子。但为你所见到的挺身而出并大声疾呼……我身在加利福尼亚州。我曾经是一名举报人。你确实必须为正确的事情挺身而出，即使没有其他人这样做。在这些大型企业和环境中，你肯定会受到挑战，因为随着时间的推移，他们已经适应了某些他们认为可以接受的行为。作为一名心理学家，我觉得自己像一台X光机，你可以看到一切，对吧？你以前看不到的东西。或者就像我戴着隐形眼镜。当我戴上隐形眼镜时，我能看得更清楚，20/20视力，对吧？我觉得作为一名心理学家，当我走进去时，我能看到人们
can't see do you feel that way do you feel like I see them clearly and sharply sometimes and I can't not see them they do but I don't always tell them that I can so I don't know if you I don't even have this in me yes yes people often say oh are you are you analyzing me or can you read my mind and and you always say no of course not but it does give you a just a I've got a real you know you need to be able to read people quickly and kind of get a feel for them because of the nature of assessments. You can't possibly spend years with somebody. You need to be able to get the information quickly and make judgments against kind of reasonable doubt and kind of, I'm not amazing at small talk. I like, I like big talk. I don't know about you, but I like to ask the big questions of people when I meet them, even if you're in, even if you're in a queue, you know, a restaurant or something like
看不到的东西。你有这种感觉吗？你觉得我能清晰敏锐地看穿他们吗？有时是的，而且我无法视而不见。他们确实如此，但我并不总是告诉他们我能看穿。所以我不知道你是否……我甚至没有这种想法。是的，是的，人们经常说：“哦，你在分析我吗？或者你能读懂我的心思吗？”你总是说：“不，当然不是。”但这确实给了你一种……你需要能够快速读懂人，并因为评估的性质而对他们有一种感觉。你不可能花几年时间去了解一个人。你需要能够快速获取信息，并在合理怀疑的基础上做出判断。我不擅长闲聊。我喜欢……我喜欢深度交流。我不知道你怎么样，但我喜欢在见到人们时问他们一些宏大的问题，即使你是在排队，在餐厅或者其他地方，
that's, that's what I like best oh I love that I love asking questions and a lot of people don't ask enough questions they just assume they make assumptions right which leads to you know not accurate So really, as a forensic psychologist, asking questions is so powerful. And you can ask the most uncomfortable questions, right? And you may be surprised on what they tell you or what you hear, but ask those questions. And as a forensic interviewer, you will be meeting with people who have murdered, raped, you know, all these things. So just you ask the questions
那是我最喜欢的。哦，我喜欢那样。我喜欢问问题，很多人问的问题不够多，他们只是假设，他们做出了假设，对吧？这导致了……不准确。所以，作为一名法医心理学家，提问是非常强大的。你可以问最令人不舒服的问题，对吧？你可能会对他们告诉你的内容或你听到的内容感到惊讶，但请问这些问题。作为一名法医面试官，你将会见到那些杀过人、强奸过人的人，你知道，所有这些事情。所以你只需要问这些问题，
and that's how you can get a lot of really good information. So you're right. Even in all my relationships, my most deepest meaningful relationships or close friends or siblings like have those deep conversations like yeah don't why make why make it superficial let's just get right into it if yeah you know if i go to personal training if i go to have a massage or a facial we are we are having a proper chat like and you know they're like oh you know i feel like you know
这就是你能获得大量非常有价值信息的方式。所以你是对的。即使在我所有的关系中，我最深刻、最有意义的关系，或者亲密的朋友或兄弟姐妹，都会进行那种深度的对话。是的，为什么要让它流于表面呢？让我们直接切入主题。如果……你知道，如果我去进行个人训练，如果我去按摩或做面部护理，我们都在进行真正的交谈。你知道，他们会说：“哦，我觉得……”你知道，
i've got more from this than i've given like oh you know I feel like you know I've got more from this than I've given you or you know I feel like this has been really really enlightening for me it's made me think about this in different ways it's almost like a single a single session intervention I don't know if that's a thing in the states but you know you might only see somebody once it's trying to make that time together as purposeful as possible. You know, singular interventions, that's something I would do. And one and done, basically, throughout my career, right for suicidal, homicidal interventions, like seeing people in the emergency room for, for psychiatric holds, all those things. it's we get one chance one opportunity like eminem says like you gotta make the most of that hour together right because that's it we may not
“我从这次交流中得到的比我付出的多。”或者“我觉得这对我来说真的非常有启发，它让我以不同的方式思考这个问题。”这几乎就像是一次单次干预。我不知道这在美国是否常见，但你知道，你可能只会见到某人一次，关键是要让在一起的时间尽可能有意义。你知道，单次干预，那是我会做的事情。基本上是一次性完成，在我的职业生涯中，对吧？针对自杀、他杀的干预，比如在急诊室看病人，进行精神科留院观察，所有这些事情。我们只有一次机会，就像阿姆（Eminem）说的那样，你必须充分利用在一起的那一个小时，对吧？因为就是这样，我们可能
ever see each other again and i have this much time to get get that information absolutely you'll like this story dana so i've got um i've-year-old and a younger one as well. But the other day, he was like, oh, mummy. He doesn't call me mummy anymore, not in public. Mum, there's this really new, cool singer. you probably haven't heard of him and I was like are you kidding me are you kidding me I was there in the 90s I was singing him with my friends and he was like what really and I think it's come about because Fortnite have been playing Eminem on some of their songs so a whole new generation of fans have appeared and it's just it's just things that come around again isn't it like it's really really bizarre that's funny I have a 14 year old and I have a 23 year old and uh it's funny because sometimes they'll say mother like I go, why don't call me mother? They're like, oh, they just sort of think it's funny now. And I'm like, why do you call me that? And they go, I feel like we have just a much more
再也不会见到对方了，我只有这么多时间来获取那些信息。绝对是这样。达娜，你会喜欢这个故事的。我有……岁和更小一点的孩子。但前几天，他说：“哦，妈咪。”他不再叫我妈咪了，不在公共场合。妈，有一位非常新、非常酷的歌手。你可能没听说过他。我说：“你在开玩笑吗？你在开玩笑吗？我在90年代就在那里了，我和朋友们一起唱他的歌。”他说：“什么？真的吗？”我想这是因为《堡垒之夜》（Fortnite）在他们的一些歌曲中播放了阿姆的歌，所以出现了一整代新的粉丝。这真是……事情又回到了原点，不是吗？这真的很奇怪。这很有趣，我有一个14岁的孩子和一个23岁的孩子。有趣的是，有时他们会叫我“母亲”。我说：“为什么？别叫我母亲。”他们说：“哦，他们只是觉得现在这样很有趣。”我说：“你们为什么那样叫我？”他们说：“我觉得我们有了一种更
professional relationship. It's kind of a joke, because growing up, I actually had to call my mom, mother, and my father, father. And I actually had to salute him and say, yes, sir, father, sir. And we had to line up. And it was really strict. Push-ups, sit-ups every morning. There was eight children children and so we were all um i think they were really trying to over organize us yeah and you know with that amount of children some element of organization you know i'm thinking of um sound of music you know lining them up you know each having their own note but is you know is that level of organization and what sounds like control, and we look at mammalian organization systems of hierarchy and dominance and subservience, and we know that goes on. But actually, for me, for a UK psychologist and human, that sounds extreme. Is that extreme in the US? Yeah, I would consider my upbringing,
专业的关系。”这有点像个玩笑，因为在成长过程中，我实际上必须叫我妈妈“母亲”，叫我父亲“父亲”。我甚至必须向他敬礼并说：“是的，长官，父亲，长官。”我们必须排队。这非常严格。每天早上做俯卧撑、仰卧起坐。有八个孩子，所以我们都……我想他们真的试图过度组织我们。是的，你知道，有那么多孩子，某种程度的组织……我在想《音乐之声》（Sound of Music），你知道，让他们排成一排，每个人都有自己的音符。但是，这种组织水平，以及听起来像是控制的东西，我们看看哺乳动物的等级制度、支配与服从的组织系统，我们知道这确实存在。但实际上，对于我这个英国心理学家和人类来说，这听起来很极端。在美国这算极端吗？是的，我会认为我的成长经历，
that's very extreme. And that's not how I would raise my children. It's not like they had parental training. They weren't psychologists, right? To be honest, I felt like I spent a lot of time parenting my parents. So growing up, this will probably make sense of why I decided to become a forensic psychologist. But growing up, my parents, there was a lot of domestic violence. And my mom and dad were both homicidal. And so my mom would have a gun pointed at my dad, or my dad would be strangling my mom out. So I was a child and I observed this and I couldn't understand. And I watched it and I still couldn't understand. It didn't really make any sense why anyone would even be that mad about anything, right? I was really dumbfounded. But I thought if I could understand, then I could help. But I really can't help and intervene on any level if I have no clue what to do. And I remember I was five. I was going to school.
那非常极端。那不是我会抚养孩子的方式。他们好像没有接受过育儿培训。他们不是心理学家，对吧？老实说，我觉得我花了很多时间在“抚养”我的父母。所以成长过程中——这可能解释了为什么我决定成为一名法医心理学家——但成长过程中，我的父母之间有很多家庭暴力。我妈妈和爸爸都有杀人倾向。所以我妈妈会用枪指着我爸爸，或者我爸爸会掐住我妈妈的脖子。我还是个孩子，我观察到了这一切，但我无法理解。我看着它，但我仍然无法理解。为什么有人会对任何事情感到那么愤怒，这根本说不通，对吧？我真的惊呆了。但我心想，如果我能理解，那么我就能提供帮助。但我如果根本不知道该怎么做，就真的无法提供任何帮助或进行干预。我记得我五岁时。我要去上学。
My mom put me in first grade when I was five, which is a little bit young. But I remember my mom standing on the porch with a gun and she was pointed at my dad. My dad was trying to drive us to school. And I remember this scene happening. And I never told anyone my entire school years ever. Not once. Why would I? Again, it goes back to why you should ask difficult questions, right? No one asked me a question, right? Besides, everything good? Are you okay? Right? No one specifically said, have you ever seen your mum point a gun at your dad
我妈妈在我五岁时让我上一年级，这有点太小了。但我记得我妈妈站在门廊上，手里拿着枪，指着我爸爸。我爸爸正试图开车送我们去学校。我记得这一幕发生了。我整个学生时代从来没有告诉过任何人。一次也没有。为什么要告诉别人呢？这又回到了为什么你应该问困难的问题，对吧？没有人问过我问题，对吧？除了“一切都好吗？你还好吗？”对吧？没有人具体问过：“你有没有见过你妈妈用枪指着你爸爸？”
right and you're not necessarily going to form those words that's what we that's what we learn isn't it if you if you ask superficial questions you'll get superficial answers you know you almost have to ask exactly the right question at the right time yeah how would i know that wasn't happening everywhere everywhere like how i must have been scary though why it must have felt did it feel scary I mean how used to because because guns are very uncommon in the UK and when they are around they're supposed to be kept in locked cabinets and on all of that jazz and you have licenses for them I know it's very different in the states but I mean it sounds like you've always grown up seeing guns.
对吧？你未必能组织出这些词汇。这就是我们所学的，不是吗？如果你问肤浅的问题，你就会得到肤浅的答案。你知道，你几乎必须在正确的时间问出正确的问题。是的，我怎么会知道那不是到处都在发生呢？到处都是……但这一定很可怕。为什么……它一定感觉……它感觉可怕吗？我的意思是，你有多习惯……因为枪支在英国非常罕见，当它们出现时，它们应该被锁在柜子里，所有这些……你知道，你有它们的许可证。我知道这在美国非常不同，但我的意思是，听起来你从小就一直看到枪。
And, you know, it wouldn't have been outlandish if you did mention that at home there was a gun, because probably lots of parents had guns at home. Right. We lived in the country, very rural, on 20 acres. We had farm animals, a garden. We're really remote. There was lots of guns and we had target practice as part of my childhood training. We, my dad trained us in weapons and we, we shot guns as a kid. I think my, I think I turned 12 and I got a 30-06, a giant rifle that was bigger than me, which I never had any interest in hunting. But anyways, people have different lived experiences. My childhood was interesting, but I observed these things and I wasn't so much understanding was important for survival. But I decided if either one of them died, like, I would be fine. Psychologically, like, and I played it out
而且，如果你提到家里有枪，那也不算离谱，因为可能很多父母家里都有枪。对吧。我们住在乡下，非常偏远，有20英亩地。我们有农场动物，有一个花园。我们非常偏远。有很多枪，而且作为我童年训练的一部分，我们有打靶练习。我父亲训练我们使用武器，我们小时候就开过枪。我想我12岁时，我得到了一把30-06步枪，一把比我还大的巨型步枪，但我对打猎从来没有任何兴趣。但无论如何，人们有不同的生活经历。我的童年很有趣，但我观察到了这些事情，理解它们对生存很重要。但我决定，如果他们中的任何一个死了，我会没事的。在心理上，我会没事的，而且我一直在脑海中演练
all the time in my head, and I would take care of the kids. But I thought it would not be good. And I would do everything I could to intervene. And then so I did. Eventually, you know, I started learning things to help them not do these things. So this sounds silly, but I started doing my mom's hair and makeup, like giving her one-on-one time, like laying out her clothes. She was depressed or like helping her for a special. She had a lot of trauma. Both my parents were victims of other types of abuse from their childhood. So, and then I just really sought to understand them. Little did I know that's kind of what psychologists do. I didn't, and I would take my siblings,
这一切，我会照顾好孩子们。但我认为那不会是好事。我会尽我所能去干预。所以我确实做了。最终，你知道，我开始学习一些东西来帮助他们不要做这些事情。这听起来很傻，但我开始帮我妈妈做头发和化妆，比如给她一对一的时间，比如帮她搭配衣服。她很抑郁，或者在特殊场合帮助她。她有很多创伤。我父母双方在童年时期都是其他类型虐待的受害者。所以，我只是真的试图去理解他们。我当时并不知道，这正是心理学家所做的事情。我不知道，我会带着我的兄弟姐妹，
and we'd lock ourselves in a room and I would read to them and I would just say, you don't, this is not right, but you can choose a different life. We're not choosing violence, like we're gonna. And so I would talk to them about how you can, we're going to grow up and we're not going to do this. And we're never going to do this. And this is wrong. I feel like you're Matilda, born into the Wormwood family. But you're so different to them. And you're a force for good.
我们把自己锁在一个房间里，我会给他们读书，我只是说：“你们不需要……这不对，但你可以选择不同的人生。我们不选择暴力，我们要……”所以我跟他们谈论你们可以……我们要长大，我们不会那样做。我们永远不会那样做。这是错的。我觉得你就像是出生在沃姆伍德（Wormwood）家庭里的玛蒂尔达（Matilda）。但你和他们太不一样了。你是一股向善的力量。
And I don't think you quite realize how special you are, actually, that you, you know, this violence and this control and abuse was inflicted emotional, possibly physically at times as well, was inflicted on you. And you were just like, yeah, this isn't this isn't right. This is not for me, you know. And actually everything we learn about trauma and violence and how it perpetuates, you're like, no, this doesn't compute. I'm not going to become violent because that's my formative experiences. And yeah, I just don't think you realize how incredible that is. And I don't know if the Matilda reference translated, I don't know if you've watched that film or if you're familiar with the book, but that's just what you conjure up for me.
我不认为你完全意识到自己有多特别，实际上，你……你知道，这种暴力、控制和虐待——情感上的，有时甚至是身体上的——被施加在你身上。而你却只是说：“是的，这不对。这不适合我。”你知道，实际上我们所了解的关于创伤、暴力以及它是如何延续的一切，你却说：“不，这不符合逻辑。我不会因为这是我的成长经历就变得暴力。”是的，我只是觉得你没有意识到这有多么不可思议。我不知道玛蒂尔达的那个比喻是否翻译得通，我不知道你是否看过那部电影，或者你是否熟悉那本书，但这正是你给我的感觉。
Yeah, I think, you know, as we study psychology, we always look at people who grew up in violence, and then that makes sense why they became a killer, or they did these horrible things. But also, let's look at the people who never became violent and grew up and did wonderful, I do great things. Later, my siblings became suicidal or homicidal to my parents, as you can understand, like as a natural response to violence or confusion, like how to make it stop. And so I spent a lot of time intervening and talking them out of that. And then when my siblings sometimes were suicidal, I remember being first confronted with it and thinking, I really don't have the skill set for this. Like, I don't feel suicidal or homicidal. I don't want to hurt anyone. I want to help everyone like love and like feel safe. So then I remember one of my siblings, you know, we went out to breakfast IHOP and she told me like she had an attempt.
是的，我想，你知道，当我们学习心理学时，我们总是观察那些在暴力中成长的人，然后这解释了为什么他们会成为杀手，或者他们做了这些可怕的事情。但同时，让我们看看那些从未变得暴力，长大后做了美妙、伟大事情的人。后来，我的兄弟姐妹变得有自杀或杀人倾向，针对我的父母，正如你可以理解的那样，这是对暴力或困惑的自然反应，比如如何让它停止。所以我花了很多时间进行干预，劝说他们放弃这些念头。然后，当我的兄弟姐妹有时有自杀倾向时，我记得第一次面对它时，我想：“我真的没有这方面的技能。我不觉得想自杀或杀人。我不想伤害任何人。我想帮助每个人，像爱一样，感觉安全。”所以后来我的一个兄弟姐妹，你知道，我们去IHOP吃早餐，她告诉我她有过一次尝试。
And then I thought, I'm really better get, I think I need to get schooled on this. Like, I don't, I'll do the best I can here, but I'm not, I don't, I don't know what to say or do exactly. I was like, if I had the skill set, well, that could be really powerful. It actually could be life saving. And I think I do think my being born into that family changed the dynamics of something horrible that could have occurred. And I spent a lot of time talking to my parents and like trying to rationalize with them and to understand them. And right, so eventually I become a psychologist. And now I understand on a much deeper level, how even complex PTSD can manifest. And while it can look like psychosis or other things that we don't understand, like understanding the correct diagnosis or the right intervention is key. And I used my words and with, you know, holding my hand out or speaking assertively like hundreds of hundreds of times, but where it stopped.
然后我想，我真的最好……我想我需要在这方面接受培训。我不……我会尽我所能，但我不知道该说什么或做什么。我想，如果我有这些技能，那可能会非常有力量。它实际上可能是救命的。而且我认为，我出生在那个家庭确实改变了一些可能发生的糟糕事情的动态。我花了很多时间与我的父母交谈，试图与他们讲道理并理解他们。所以，最终我成为了一名心理学家。现在我更深刻地理解了复杂的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）是如何表现的。虽然它看起来可能像精神病或其他我们不理解的东西，但理解正确的诊断或正确的干预是关键。我用了我的话，用……伸出我的手或坚定地说话……数百次，但它停止了。
And so I learned a lot through my experience. And then it was, it gave me a skill set to be really comfortable working with violent offenders who were dangerous and threatening and homicidal or suicidal. And I was like, oh, I can get paid to do this. I've been doing it for free for like 25 years. I would like a paycheck, please. For my adolescence yeah I would like I should have been getting paid top dollar so absolutely I do find so it can be a gift to take something you've been through and use it um as you I can say I have experience, right?
所以我从我的经历中学到了很多。然后，它给了我一套技能，让我能非常从容地与那些危险、具有威胁性、有杀人或自杀倾向的暴力罪犯一起工作。我当时想：“哦，我可以靠做这个赚钱？我已经免费做了25年了。请给我发工资。”为了我的青春期……是的，我应该得到高薪，所以绝对的，我确实发现，把你经历过的事情拿出来，并利用它……我可以说是“我有经验”，对吧？
You do, you do. And it feels like you almost could have gone on to be a hostage negotiator or forensic psychologist, like could have gone either way. No, totally. that are so fragile, right? Just a moment away, right? From something tragic happening. What to say and do in that moment. Like that's like those moments that can change everything. Absolutely. Can I ask the birth order in your family where did you come in the eight so i know people that that's a whole the psychology of birth order right
你确实有，你确实有。感觉你几乎可以去当人质谈判专家或法医心理学家，这两种职业都有可能。不，完全是这样。那些非常脆弱的人，对吧？距离发生悲剧只有一瞬间，对吧？在那一刻该说什么、做什么。那些时刻可以改变一切。绝对是这样。我可以问一下你在家里的出生顺序吗？你在八个孩子中排第几？因为我知道人们……出生顺序的心理学，对吧？
uh people can have that's a whole study in itself but i'm in the middle. I just, I did have a sibling that died. Um, so that would make nine. So I'm sorry to hear that. So, so I'm in the middle. So I actually was the baby. I was the youngest for at least, um, six years. Then there was a sibling that died after me. And then there was a gap, I think seven years between the next sibling. So I was the youngest of the top four and the oldest of the next crew. Uh, so I was, I had, I was the youngest and then the middle, but also the oldest. So eventually when the, when the oldest three moved out, I was the oldest of the younger siblings. So I changed their diapers, took them to school, helped them with homework, did all the things.
人们可以有……这本身就是一门研究，但我排在中间。我确实有一个兄弟姐妹去世了。所以那应该是九个。我很遗憾听到这个消息。所以，我排在中间。所以我实际上是最小的。我至少有六年是最小的。然后在我之后有一个兄弟姐妹去世了。然后有一个间隔，我想在下一个兄弟姐妹之间有七年。所以我前四个孩子里是最小的，后一批里是最大的。所以，我既是最小的，也是中间的，但也是最大的。所以最终，当最大的三个搬出去后，我是较小兄弟姐妹中最大的。所以我给他们换尿布，带他们去上学，帮他们做作业，做了所有的事情。
And I started working the day I turned 13. I was a nanny for four kids plus there was three kids at home so I was like quite busy and uh I it was it just felt like a lot of responsibility yeah and it you know it's reminding me of something you said earlier that you were like you'd rationalized almost that you could cope if your parents died. It's almost like a dissociation forward slash like a defense, like a fracturing that you kind of you're just existing. You know, you're using their resources to to exploit so that you can survive. You know, they're feeding you, they're clothing you.
我13岁生日那天就开始工作了。我给四个孩子当保姆，家里还有三个孩子，所以我非常忙。这感觉责任重大。是的，这让我想起了你之前说的一件事，你说你几乎合理化了如果你父母去世你也能应付。这几乎就像是一种解离，或者是一种防御，一种破碎，你只是在生存。你知道，你在利用他们的资源来剥削，以便你能生存。你知道，他们在喂养你，他们在给你穿衣服。
But actually, you're raising yourself, they're clothing you, but actually you're raising yourself and you're not relying upon anybody. You're doing this yourself. Correct. So food, like clothing, shelter, we're covered. We got food from the government, had these brown bags. They'd give you a big chunk of cheese, and a can of pork. And it was cornmeal, cornmeal, and we would make cornmeal mush,
但实际上，你在抚养你自己，他们在给你穿衣服，但实际上你在抚养你自己，你不依赖任何人。你自己做这一切。没错。所以食物、衣服、住所，我们都有了。我们从政府那里得到食物，有这些棕色的袋子。他们会给你一大块奶酪和一罐猪肉。那是玉米粉，玉米粉，我们会做玉米粉糊，
make it into breakfast cereal. Anyway, so and yeah, I mean, we had basic things. But so then I just thought, well, you could I could work and I could cover all my basic needs. Right. And so, you know. Okay, so this is funny. I think Okay. So like I'm desperate, right? They had this thing called the homespun fair. It's like people made jams or jellies or aprons or, so I made pin cushions as in like people that sew, my mom sewed our clothes. I didn't sew. I wasn't interested. I made pin cushions as a child. I took an old can of tuna, like wash it out. You have a can, you have a circle and I put stuffing in it, like put cloth over it as for a pin cushion. And then I made a circle cardboard under it. So it was like a hat. So I hot glued lace, dolled it up. I sold them like $7. So without knowing it, right? That's, I sold them at the fair. And I remember making my first sell. And I was like, really proud, right? You sold two pin cushions. And how silly you said, like you felt so silly starting out like you and I felt silly, but I was like, I don't know what else to do. I
把它做成早餐麦片。总之，是的，我的意思是，我们有基本的东西。但后来我就想，好吧，我可以工作，我可以支付我所有的基本需求。对吧。所以，你知道。好吧，这很有趣。我想……好吧。就像我很绝望，对吧？他们有一种东西叫“家庭手工艺博览会”（homespun fair）。就像人们制作果酱、果冻或围裙，所以我制作了针垫，就像那些缝纫的人一样，我妈妈缝我们的衣服。我不缝纫。我不感兴趣。我小时候制作针垫。我拿了一个旧金枪鱼罐头，洗干净。你有一个罐头，你有一个圆圈，我在里面放了填充物，像用布盖住它作为针垫。然后我在下面放了一个圆形的纸板。所以它就像一顶帽子。所以我用热熔胶粘上蕾丝，装饰一下。我以7美元的价格卖掉了它们。所以不知不觉中，对吧？我在博览会上卖掉了它们。我记得我完成了第一笔销售。我当时真的很自豪，对吧？你卖了两个针垫。你说你刚开始时感觉很傻，就像你和我一样，我感觉很傻，但我当时想，我不知道还能做什么。我
don't have a lot of resources, right? But I'm industrious enough to be like, I've got cloth, cardboard, an old tuna can, like some old stuffing from an old pillow. But sometimes we just do what we got to do. Absolutely. And you pull that out the bag, as we say. And I think that's probably the difference, really. I probably felt silly, because I actually didn't really at this time need the money. I was still working three days a week in the NHS, which is our health service here. And I started my business because my husband had said,
没有很多资源，对吧？但我足够勤奋，我想：“我有布、纸板、一个旧金枪鱼罐头，还有旧枕头里的一些旧填充物。”但有时我们只是做我们必须做的事情。绝对是这样。而且你把它从包里拿出来，正如我们所说的那样。我认为这可能就是区别所在，真的。我可能觉得傻，因为我当时其实并不真的需要钱。我还在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作，那是我们这里的医疗服务机构，每周工作三天。我创办我的企业是因为我丈夫说：
well, what are you going to do when our youngest starts preschool? Because you don't work, you know, there's two mornings a week when you usually would have him. And I was thinking, I don't know, go for a facial, you know, have a nap, you know, catch up on the chaos of the last three years. know go for a facial you know have a nap you know catch up on the chaos of the last three years um and he was like you could start a business and I was like I suppose I could so that's that's how my business was born but I initially was so scared of spending any money lest I not have any money to um to pay my taxes with um because in the uk if you're employed your taxes are taken off at
“当我们的老幺开始上学前班时，你打算做什么？因为你不工作，你知道，通常你会有两个上午的时间。”我当时在想：“我不知道，去做个面部护理，你知道，小睡一会儿，你知道，补上过去三年混乱的睡眠。”你知道，去做个面部护理，你知道，小睡一会儿，你知道，补上过去三年混乱的睡眠。他当时说：“你可以创办一家企业。”我说：“我想我可以。”所以这就是我的企业诞生的方式。但我最初非常害怕花任何钱，生怕我没有钱去……去支付我的税款……因为在英国，如果你是受雇的，你的税款是在
source you don't need to do any of that um whereas when you're self-employed you're responsible for reporting that and working out your expenses and all of that jazz um so i just saved other than my costs i needed to run my business like room hire and indemnity and all of that I just saved the rest of it um so I think it's probably that's the difference that's probably what made me feel a bit silly it wasn't life or death for me at that time it was just a bit of self-actualization and something to do with my time and then it was only over over the development of that and then actually during covid that I really began to take myself seriously and then I I then it's almost three years to the day that I've become fully self-employed and it's probably something about that that I now need
源头扣除的，你不需要做任何这些事情。而当你是个体经营者时，你有责任报告这些并计算你的开支以及所有这些琐事。所以我只是存钱，除了我经营企业所需的成本，比如租房、赔偿金等等，我只是把剩下的存起来。所以我认为这可能就是区别，这可能就是让我感到有点傻的原因。当时对我来说这不是生死攸关的事，这只是某种自我实现，以及用我的时间做点什么。然后只是在它的发展过程中，特别是在新冠疫情期间，我才真正开始认真对待自己。然后……距离我完全成为个体经营者已经快三年了，可能就是因为这个原因，我现在需要
the money I'm earning so I'm striving for it more and you know it's it's the little girl who's selling pin cushions you you know, I'm gonna, I'm gonna talk to you to see if you want to buy any of my pin cushions, because actually, I need to pay my mortgage. I love it. I, I, I feel the same way about starting my business, the financial aspect and taxes was the most challenging because that's not my specialty is not finances. And so it's been two years for me doing my own business. And there's a lot I've learned. And I'm continuing to learn things are getting better. To be more
我赚的钱，所以我更努力地去争取。而且你知道，这就是那个卖针垫的小女孩，你……你知道，我要和你谈谈，看看你是否想买我的针垫，因为实际上，我需要支付我的抵押贷款。我喜欢它。我……我在创办企业方面也有同样的感觉，财务方面和税收是最具挑战性的，因为那不是我的专长，我的专长不是财务。所以，我经营自己的企业已经两年了。我学到了很多。我还在继续学习，事情正在好转。变得更
organized, right? Because you're, because I'm also right, the CEO, so I have to do all these other things. I'm working on negotiating contracts with agencies, governmental and county agencies, and I am getting those. And there's a lot of things you have to do to get in that position. And I don't know, I feel like it's been a lot of hats for me. But eventually my goal is to step back just a bit so that I can oversee the business and hire people and interns to do the work and I can oversee it. And right now I'm doing so many reports and a bit more than I would like to be doing. And I'm setting it up. I'm taking my first three interns next month.
很有条理，对吧？因为我也是首席执行官，所以我必须处理所有其他事情。我正在努力与各机构、政府和县级机构协商合同，并且正在取得进展。要达到那个位置，你必须做很多事情。我不知道，我觉得自己承担了太多角色。但我的最终目标是稍微退后一步，这样我就可以监督业务，雇佣人员和实习生来完成工作，而我负责监督。目前我正在处理太多的报告，比我想要的要多。我正在进行安排。下个月我将迎来我的前三名实习生。
And I'll be training them. And they'll start doing some evaluations. And my goal is to truly move over to be more of a CEO and do more consulting work, less report writing. I'm doing some fun things now that I didn't think originally. When you start out to do your own business, you're not really sure how it's going to go, right? You're hoping for the best, but it's an adventure. There's unknowns. But this year, I've had people reach out to me for cold cases, like I'm working some wild cases, crossing over to civil law lawsuits. And I'm, you know, doing my podcast killer psychologist podcast, where we're doing some cold case exploration, and getting some
我将对他们进行培训。他们将开始进行一些评估。我的目标是真正转型为更纯粹的首席执行官，做更多的咨询工作，减少报告撰写。我现在做了一些有趣的事情，这是我最初没想到的。当你开始创业时，你并不确定事情会如何发展，对吧？你希望一切顺利，但这是一种冒险。有很多未知数。但今年，有人联系我处理悬案，比如我正在处理一些棘手的案件，涉及民事诉讼。而且，你知道，我还在做我的播客《杀手心理学家》，我们在那里进行一些悬案探索，并获得了一些
fascinating stories. And it's fun, it gets in touch with my creative side or storytelling, that Nancy Drew side of me. Okay, good. You know what Nancy Drew is, right? So just that, like your love for my curiosity. I need mystery. I like to investigate. And so there's some television shows that I'll be on this year, or some other ones in the works, where I get to explain things, right, from the perspective of some of these offenders. vendors and that is interesting to me because i want to challenge how people think about things like to get into the minds of some of these people i like to explain that and help people understand it and not everything you know is common knowledge and i also want to prevent people from becoming these right horrific individuals I'm explaining it. I like to explain it to parents and children. And I work with adolescents in juvenile hall who've committed crimes,
引人入胜的故事。这很有趣，它触及了我的创造力或讲故事的一面，也就是我身上南希·朱尔（Nancy Drew）的那一面。好的，很好。你知道南希·朱尔是谁，对吧？就是那样，就像你对我的好奇心的热爱一样。我需要神秘感。我喜欢调查。所以今年我会有一些电视节目，或者还有一些正在筹备中，在那里我有机会解释事情，对吧，从这些罪犯的角度。这对我来说很有趣，因为我想挑战人们对事物的看法，我想进入这些人的内心世界，我喜欢解释这一点并帮助人们理解它，并不是你知道的一切都是常识。我也想防止人们成为这些可怕的个体。我正在解释它。我喜欢向父母和孩子解释。我在少年管教所与犯下罪行的青少年一起工作，
including murder. And so I meet with them. And I think I have four right now with reports I need to write. But I can make recommendations right to the court about where, who, where they go, what their treatment is, where they transfer to. And so that's the part I like intervention because I do have people follow up. I have one case right now, a tragic case, a boy that was being abused in a number of ways,
包括谋杀。所以我与他们会面。我想我现在有四个需要写报告的案例。但我可以向法院提出建议，关于他们去哪里、谁去、他们的治疗方案是什么、他们被转移到哪里。这就是我喜欢的干预部分，因为我确实有后续跟进的人。我现在有一个案例，一个悲剧性的案例，一个男孩在多方面受到虐待，
using drugs, having psychosis, got in trouble in a psychotic state, got violent with someone. So I did a mental health diversion evaluation. So I assessed that he needs mental health treatment. Instead of going to potentially prison, he was turning 18. And I've, over the last eight months, I've kept in touch because I've written, I'll be writing my third report to the court with a status update. And he's just doing wonderful. Has a job.
吸毒，患有精神病，在精神病状态下惹了麻烦，对某人实施了暴力。所以我做了一份心理健康分流评估。所以我评估出他需要心理健康治疗。他不用去可能入狱的地方，他快18岁了。在过去的八个月里，我一直保持联系，因为我已经写了报告，我将向法院提交第三份带有状态更新的报告。他做得非常好。有了一份工作。
No psychosis. Doing so well. And so he's so grateful. His life has changed. Like his tourney's happy. There's so many great stories to share like that where you get to see it. And you're like, yeah, I have a purpose in life. Good things can happen. And they can happen because of you.
没有精神病。做得很好。他非常感激。他的生活改变了。就像他的律师很高兴一样。有这么多伟大的故事可以分享，当你看到这些时，你会觉得，是的，我的人生有目标。好事会发生。而且它们会因为你而发生。
Yeah. Oh, well, you almost moved me to tears there. That's lovely. Like, you know, you're able to achieve those results for people and with people. It's incredible. Well done you. Tell us a little bit more about your podcast. How, How is that all going? And give us a flavor of what that's like. Killer Psychologist podcast is, well, you know, I'm killing it. But so it's not about just killers or killer psychology, but like, let's highlight the killer skill set of these investigators and these people that work on these cases, not the actual killers themselves, but like people that when I, that are interested in getting into this career field,
是的。哦，好吧，你差点让我热泪盈眶。那太可爱了。就像，你知道，你能够为人们并与人们一起取得这些成果。这太不可思议了。做得好。再多告诉我们一点关于你的播客的事。这一切进展如何？给我们讲讲那是什么样的。《杀手心理学家》播客是，嗯，你知道，我做得很好。但这不仅仅是关于杀手或杀手心理，而是，让我们突出这些调查人员和处理这些案件的人的杀手级技能，而不是杀手本身，而是那些当我，对进入这个职业领域感兴趣的人，
you, maybe you want to be a private investigator or a law enforcement officer or forensic psychologist, like, listen to us, we have these experts on there, they're sharing how they saw this case, how they worked through it, like, highlight their skill set, what they're doing, donate to their nonprofit, like, we're helping find people, we're digging up bodies, or like, we're bringing justice, let's stop focusing on these criminals, and highlighting them and giving them all this attention. Like, what about the skill set of a forensic psychologist? Don't you think that's interesting? I do. I do. I do. And the people that want to become a forensic psychologist,
你，也许你想成为一名私家侦探或执法人员或法医心理学家，听听我们，我们有这些专家在上面，他们分享他们是如何看待这个案件的，他们是如何解决它的，突出他们的技能，他们在做什么，捐赠给他们的非营利组织，就像，我们正在帮助寻找人，我们正在挖掘尸体，或者我们正在伸张正义，让我们停止关注这些罪犯，并突出他们并给予他们所有这些关注。就像，法医心理学家的技能怎么样？你不觉得那很有趣吗？我确实觉得。我确实觉得。而且那些想成为法医心理学家的人，
just kind of open up your mind. It's not how you see it on TV. Like this is, I'm real. And this is what I do. And so I think it's helpful for a lot of people that maybe want to get in this career field, but they're not, they're confused on how to become a forensic psychologist. So they want to know what I do. You know, is she going to crime scenes? So not really, but I could. But the reality is, who's going to pay you to do that? And so the reality is, after crimes have been committed, then I do their psych eval. And I'm ordered by the court. But I'm also retained by attorneys and individuals in the community. So I think killer psychologist is good for just anybody that's curious about true crime or want to be a forensic psychologist or even any career within forensic psychology, because we have some killer PIs on the show
只是打开你的思维。这不像你在电视上看到的那样。这是，我是真实的。这就是我所做的。所以我认为这对很多可能想进入这个职业领域但对如何成为法医心理学家感到困惑的人很有帮助。所以他们想知道我做什么。你知道，她去犯罪现场吗？其实并没有，但我可以。但现实是，谁会付钱让你做那个？所以现实是，在犯罪发生后，我做他们的心理评估。我是由法院下令的。但我也被律师和社区中的个人聘用。所以我认为《杀手心理学家》对任何对真实犯罪感到好奇或想成为法医心理学家，甚至对法医心理学内的任何职业感兴趣的人来说都是好的，因为我们在节目中有一些杀手级的私家侦探
and my co-host, who's a forensic psychologist. He's also a retired law enforcement officer. He's also an attorney. So there's a lot of like this critical thinking. So I really want people to think through things. So we have an episode that's out. It's like, oh, what day is it? Wednesday. So, and it's about OJ Simpson
还有我的联合主持人，他是一位法医心理学家。他也是一名退休的执法人员。他也是一名律师。所以有很多批判性思维。所以我真的希望人们能深入思考。所以我们有一集已经发布了。就像，哦，今天是星期几？星期三。所以，它是关于OJ·辛普森的
and the potential of an accomplice with him. There was a man with him, and I'm sure OJ Simpson. He just died. So is this just exceptionally well-timed, or had you already planned this before? Funny thing is, we already wanted to do the story because a private investigator just done a whole investigator report on that, that homicide. And he was involved with this. There's like a whole backstory.
以及他有同伙的可能性。有一个人和他在一起，我肯定OJ·辛普森。他刚刚去世了。所以这是时间安排得特别好，还是你之前就已经计划好了？有趣的是，我们本来就想做这个故事，因为一位私家侦探刚刚对那起凶杀案做了一份完整的调查报告。他参与了这件事。这背后有一个完整的故事。
You can listen to the podcast. But there was another person with him that night. And it also involves the mob. And it gets complicated. The justice system isn't always just just OJ got away with murder, just in case anyone hasn't figured that out. But and he also in civil court was ordered to pay. And as of yesterday, the attorney for OJ's estate said he's going to make sure that family never gets a penny. And this is even after OJ's dead. So the system isn't just he got away with murder in criminal court and he didn't pay any money in civil court.
你可以听听播客。但那天晚上还有另一个人和他在一起。而且它还涉及黑帮。这变得复杂了。司法系统并不总是公正的，OJ逃脱了谋杀罪，以防有人还没弄明白。但是，他在民事法庭也被判赔偿。截至昨天，OJ遗产的律师说他要确保那个家庭永远拿不到一分钱。即使在OJ死后也是如此。所以系统并不公正，他在刑事法庭逃脱了谋杀罪，在民事法庭也没有支付任何钱。
But the story is interesting when we give you the whole. Well, the guys I'm working with have the whole discovery file, and audio recordings, crime scene evidence, the whole investigation. So we're giving out this information, we want people to think about it. Why? How did this happen? And it's interesting, if anything, right. But I also want to encourage critical thinking. So people may have preconceived theories about this case. But what if you didn't know this? What if I told you there was two murder weapons? What if I mean, more? Now, are you wondering, well, how did that happen? Like, how does this make sense? And I will go back to ethics for anyone wanting to get into this field. Yeah, there's people that can pay the media not to share certain information, law enforcement officers taking bribes, there's blackmail, there's a collusion, there's a lot of different things. Episode of Sopran sopranos isn't it
但当我们给你完整的故事时，这个故事很有趣。嗯，和我一起工作的人有完整的证据文件、录音、犯罪现场证据，整个调查。所以我们正在发布这些信息，我们希望人们思考它。为什么？这是怎么发生的？如果有什么的话，这很有趣，对吧。但我也想鼓励批判性思维。所以人们可能对这个案件有先入为主的理论。但如果你不知道这个呢？如果我告诉你当时有两把凶器呢？如果我意思是，更多呢？现在，你在想，嗯，那是怎么发生的？就像，这怎么说得通？我会回到伦理问题，给任何想进入这个领域的人。是的，有人可以付钱给媒体不分享某些信息，执法人员收受贿赂，有勒索，有勾结，有很多不同的事情。《黑道家族》的一集，不是吗
like it's all going on right and so that so that murder trial is well sadly it taught me that was happening right when i was graduating from high school um it taught me one thing. First of all, I thought, oh, like your ex-husband can murder you and get away with it. And huh, I don't really feel good about that. I hope someone, if someone killed me, someone would avenge my death or justice would prevail even after I was gone. So that also inspired me to be... It's part of being human, really. You have to believe that. Otherwise, how can you live? It feels like a lawless state. Why would any of us follow any of the rules if there's no consequences? That is the very nature of our human society. that's what stops us from going out and committing all
就像这一切都在发生，对吧，所以那场谋杀审判，可悲的是，它教会了我，那正是我高中毕业时发生的事情，嗯，它教会了我一件事。首先，我想，哦，就像你的前夫可以谋杀你并逃脱惩罚。而且，嗯，我对此感觉不太好。我希望有人，如果有人杀了我也许会为我报仇，或者即使我走了，正义也会伸张。所以这也激励了我成为……这实际上是作为人类的一部分。你必须相信这一点。否则，你怎么能活下去？这感觉像是一个无法无天的状态。如果没有后果，我们为什么要遵守任何规则？这正是我们人类社会的本质。这就是阻止我们出去犯下所有
these horrendous crimes is because we believe in the consequences of that and so if there aren't any it really does turn everything on its head well and there aren't any consequences for these people they've gotten away with a lot of things over time and even now. And that's not right. So I feel like I have a good sense of justice and I encounter a lot of horrific cases where people are still killing or committing violent sexual acts. And there's things we can do to stop it. So law enforcement doesn't always have the resources. So you're seeing more private investigators who are basically independent can help, right?
这些可怕罪行的原因，是因为我们相信后果，所以如果没有后果，它真的会把一切都颠倒过来。嗯，这些人没有后果，他们随着时间的推移逃脱了很多事情，即使是现在。这不对。所以我感觉我有很好的正义感，我遇到了很多可怕的案件，人们仍然在杀人或犯下暴力的性行为。我们可以做些事情来阻止它。所以执法部门并不总是有资源。所以你看到更多的私家侦探，他们基本上是独立的，可以提供帮助，对吧？
Track down criminals, get confessions, like do a thorough analysis. Sometimes they're just handing it to law enforcement. We're doing right now in a few cases I'm working on. That's what's happening. We want law enforcement to reopen some of these cases. And what my podcast can do is help bring awareness to some of these murders who've people gotten away with murder. It's like, let's reopen this case. Like, here's all the information. And I just had a PI message me last night. It's a cold case in Florida.
追踪罪犯，获得供词，进行彻底的分析。有时他们只是把它交给执法部门。我们现在正在处理的几个案件中，就是这种情况。这就是正在发生的事情。我们希望执法部门重新开启其中一些案件。我的播客可以做的是帮助提高对其中一些谋杀案的认识，那些人逃脱了谋杀罪。就像，让我们重新开启这个案件。就像，这里是所有的信息。我昨晚刚收到一位私家侦探的消息。这是佛罗里达州的一起悬案。
This man, young man, murdered his girlfriend and is on the run, but we're zooming in on him, right? And, like, they can get away with it for so many years until, right, somebody starts looking in a little deeper, even after the case is closed or he wasn't even charged. But you start getting this information. So it's important. This is how we don't you want to feel safe in society? Don't you want to know?
这个男人，年轻人，谋杀了他的女朋友，正在逃亡，但我们正在聚焦于他，对吧？而且，他们可以逃脱惩罚很多年，直到，有人开始深入调查，即使在案件结案后，或者他甚至没有被指控。但你开始得到这些信息。所以这很重要。这就是我们，你不想在社会中感到安全吗？你不想知道吗？
How can we live if people just can get away with murder? How can we raise our children if we believe that the world is unsafe and unjust? And it isn't safe, but I'm going to do my part to help people feel safe. So like going back to my childhood, like feeling safe is just a basic need. Like if you can't feel safe, I mean, like you can't really flourish or exist well in the world, you know. So one of the things that I love to do as a forensic psychologist or that I have done, teaching people to communicate their wants and needs assertively without using violence. So violence prevention, and it's something I see that violence is still every day, there's horrific violence happening. And it's Martin Luther King said that violence is the language of the unspoken. And I always that
如果人们只是可以逃脱谋杀罪，我们怎么能活下去？如果我们认为世界是不安全和不公正的，我们怎么能抚养我们的孩子？它确实不安全，但我会尽我的一份力量帮助人们感到安全。所以回到我的童年，感觉安全只是一个基本需求。就像如果你不能感到安全，我的意思是，你不能真正地在世界上繁荣或存在，你知道。所以作为一名法医心理学家，我喜欢做的一件事，或者我已经做过的事情，就是教人们自信地表达他们的需求，而不使用暴力。所以暴力预防，这是我每天都能看到的，暴力仍然存在，每天都有可怕的暴力发生。马丁·路德·金说暴力是未说出口的语言。我总是
always resonates with me because they are communicating something. And as forensic psychologists, we decipher what that message is. And so I've met with so many people who tell me what their message was. And I get it. But I understand message received. But how could we have communicated this without, right, these mass killing sprees and things so i think i just feel like i have a sense of responsibility to like educate and provide information or but you don't keep calm way you are so calm you calm me as well i feel like i'm just gonna hang out more with Dana and just slow everything down and it's really really nice um I just yeah I find you very easy to be with and
总是引起我的共鸣，因为他们正在传达某种东西。作为法医心理学家，我们破译那个信息是什么。所以我见过很多人告诉我他们的信息是什么。我明白了。但我理解信息已收到。但我们怎么能在没有这些大规模杀戮狂潮和类似事情的情况下传达这一点呢？所以我认为我只是觉得我有责任去教育和提供信息，或者，但你保持冷静的方式，你太冷静了，你也让我冷静下来，我觉得我只是想和达娜多待一会儿，把一切都慢下来，这真的真的很好，嗯，我只是，是的，我觉得和你在一起很容易，而且
yeah I just really enjoy really enjoy time with you I feel like we're a little bit less naughty when we're on record than we are when we're off but yeah it's just it's just i've really enjoyed our chat where can people listen to your podcast where's the best place for them to do that or to watch that i don't i don't know if you're a visual podcast as well well you know i'm kind of a visual person so i'm putting the podcast on youtube that way you can see us if you want, my giant talking head, but you can comment and interact with us and like have meaningful conversations, get connected. So Killer Psychologist on YouTube, KillerPsychologistPodcast.com. My company is PsychologyDoctor.com. My company is psychologydoctor.com. That's psychologydr.com.
是的，我真的很享受和你在一起的时间。我觉得我们在录音时比我们私下里稍微不那么淘气一点，但是的，这只是，我真的很享受我们的聊天。人们可以在哪里收听你的播客？他们去哪里做这件事最好，或者去哪里看？我不知道你是否也是一个视觉播客。嗯，你知道我是一个视觉型的人，所以我把播客放在YouTube上，这样如果你想看的话，你可以看到我们，我巨大的说话头，但你可以评论并与我们互动，像进行有意义的对话，建立联系。所以YouTube上的《杀手心理学家》，KillerPsychologistPodcast.com。我的公司是PsychologyDoctor.com。我的公司是psychologydoctor.com。那是psychologydr.com。
And so it's a forensic psychology consulting firm. And I work with a lot of courts and I do court appointed psych evals. And I think the podcast was created just to have a creative outlet to write just to be social and also have fun so we're actually just really having fun on the podcast so if because I want people to have fun so right the other PIs the other psychologists we get together and chat we're actually laughing in between before and after, we're calling each other after we're talking. We love each other. It's not, it's just, we need that human connection. And we're people too. We want to have fun. Like we're not it's not all serious and uptight. Like we do this. And we're so smart and clever. We're like robots. No, we're just, we just want to, we're just sharing for educational purposes. And I think that if
所以它是一家法医心理学咨询公司。我和很多法院合作，我做法院指定的心理评估。我认为播客的创建只是为了有一个创造性的出口，去写作，去社交，也为了好玩，所以我们实际上在播客上玩得很开心，所以如果因为我希望人们玩得开心，所以其他的私家侦探，其他的心理学家，我们聚在一起聊天，我们实际上在之前和之后都在笑，我们在之后互相打电话，我们在交谈。我们彼此相爱。这不是，这只是，我们需要那种人际联系。我们也是人。我们想玩得开心。就像我们不是，这并不全是严肃和紧张的。就像我们这样做。而且我们非常聪明和机智。我们就像机器人。不，我们只是，我们只是想，我们只是为了教育目的而分享。我认为如果
people want to tune in and listen and like be a part of that community, we're really receptive and open to people connecting and commenting on YouTube. And I have a love for helping educate the next generation of people that are interested in going to this career field. So a lot of the content's really helpful. What does a forensic psychologist do? Well, I'll tell you what we do. Just tune in. And there's a lot of good information. And lastly, I would say I'll do episodes specifically based on what people want. So careers in forensic psychology, careers in criminal justice, like different career options for people to get information about. Because I really want the future generation to be interested in this see its value instead of going and pursuing only fans or being a stripper or selling your body there's so many different things that people are doing because they want to make
人们想收听并成为那个社区的一部分，我们非常乐意并开放人们在YouTube上联系和评论。我有一种帮助教育下一代对这个职业领域感兴趣的人的热情。所以很多内容真的很有帮助。法医心理学家做什么？嗯，我会告诉你我们做什么。只要收听就行了。有很多好的信息。最后，我会说我会根据人们想要的内容专门制作剧集。比如法医心理学的职业，刑事司法的职业，比如人们可以获得信息的不同职业选择。因为我真的希望未来的一代对这个感兴趣，看到它的价值，而不是去追求OnlyFans或成为脱衣舞娘或出卖你的身体，人们因为想赚钱而做的事情太多了，
money but it's valuing themselves or like i still believe that education is very is so important and valuable it's it's not just achieving the degree or the certificate or hanging that plaque on your wall it's how it's changed my thinking right made me a better a better person and one that can be of use and of value well I think you sound like an incredibly useful, valuable person. And we obviously share the same passion for upskilling the next generation as well. It's really important to me. I know you are on Instagram as well, aren't you? You are Dr. Dana underscore Anderson. So people should come and follow you there as well. It has been the biggest pleasure speaking with you. I've absolutely loved it. Wishing you well with whatever comes next for you and do stay in touch with me
但这是在重视他们自己，或者像我仍然相信教育是非常重要和有价值的。这不仅仅是获得学位或证书或把那块牌匾挂在墙上，而是它如何改变了我的思维，让我成为一个更好的人，一个可以有用和有价值的人。嗯，我觉得你听起来是一个非常有用的、有价值的人。我们显然也分享着提升下一代技能的同样热情。这对我来说真的很重要。我知道你也在Instagram上，对吧？你是Dr. Dana underscore Anderson。所以人们也应该去那里关注你。和你交谈真是最大的荣幸。我绝对喜欢它。祝你接下来的一切顺利，一定要和我保持联系
because I just really like you. Girl crush time. Oh, you're so sweet and kind. And thank you for just being a good human and a good soul and, and, and being, bringing good to the world. Yeah, thank you. Well, ditto. Thank you again.
因为我真的很喜欢你。女孩崇拜时间。哦，你太甜美和善良了。谢谢你作为一个好人，一个好的灵魂，并且带来美好到这个世界。是的，谢谢。嗯，彼此彼此。再次感谢。
Honestly, I absolutely loved that. Thank you to our guest, Dr. Dana. Please do go and subscribe and follow, like her content on YouTube. She's Dr. Dana Anderson. And you can also follow her on Instagram and on LinkedIn too. I loved speaking with her. What did you think? Come and let me know. Come and discuss with me in my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And that is also the home of our new live series called Marianne's Motivation and Mindset. Come and join the conversation. Let me know who you are. Let me
老实说，我绝对喜欢那个。感谢我们的嘉宾，达娜博士。请一定要去订阅和关注，喜欢她在YouTube上的内容。她是达娜·安德森博士。你也可以在Instagram和LinkedIn上关注她。我喜欢和她交谈。你觉得怎么样？来告诉我。来在我的免费Facebook群组中和我讨论，与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起的《有抱负的心理学家社区》。这也是我们名为“玛丽安的动力与心态”的新直播系列的主场。来加入对话。让我知道你是谁。让我
know what you need from me. And if you love what I do, if you love the podcast, if you love the books, the Clinical Psychologist Collective, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, I think you'll also really like the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Thank you so much for trusting me to be part of your world and to help you on this fantastic journey of psychology. I would love your thoughts and, you know, I just love having you be part of my world. Thank you so much. Take care and be kind. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories
知道你需要我什么。如果你喜欢我所做的，如果你喜欢这个播客，如果你喜欢这些书，《临床心理学家集体》、《有抱负的心理学家集体》，我想你也会非常喜欢《有抱负的心理学家会员资格》。非常感谢你信任我成为你世界的一部分，并帮助你踏上这段美妙的心理学之旅。我很想听听你的想法，而且，你知道，我只是喜欢让你成为我世界的一部分。非常感谢。保重，保持善良。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你就会走上获得资格的道路。这是与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同故事的内容非常有趣
and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。